Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, Congressman Ro Khanna, representing
California's 17th district, which includes
Silicon Valley, joining us today from a car
very much.
Great.
Great to have you back on.
Speaker 6: David Pakman are always, of course,
always safe.
Speaker 1: So, OK.
Supply chain shortages, gas prices, a charge
squeeze from China that are expected to be
Christmas gifts.
You know, there's this there's this broad
range of what is milk cost, what do toys cost,
et cetera.
Initially, there was the idea that this is
a demand resurgence after there was a demand
evaporation during the pandemic.
It's now pretty clear that it's more than
that.
But what's your kind of general assessment
of what we're seeing right now?
Speaker 6: Well, we're seeing inflation, and
this is why we need two things we need to
pass bill back better, which would put more
money in the pockets of working families so
that they can pay for their groceries and
gas.
It would lower prescription drug prices.
It would deal with some of the supply chain
issues by investing money in our ports, by
providing an incentive for people to return,
to return to work.
And so we need to pass it.
And then the said, you know, as Larry Summers
has said, the Fed needs to make sure that
they stop, in my view, the the mortgage buybacks
and stop increasing the money supply that's
largely on the Fed and they can take that
action.
Speaker 1: Let's pick one item, which is gas
prices, because it gets so much attention.
You know, for years, I have not participated
in the you either blame or praise the president
for what's going on, but gas prices have been.
My best assessment is if a president wants,
they can tap into the strategic reserve, which
will eventually lower gas prices maybe 18
to 20 cents a gallon on what might be a temporary
basis.
I mean, it seems really that presidents don't
have very much to do with gas prices, but
yet it's a very popular political football
to throw around, isn't it?
Speaker 6: Well, this president, I think,
did the right thing by having tapping the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve 18 cents per gallon
is significant.
I mean, that means a lot to folks or who are
struggling.
But in terms of dramatically lowering prices,
it has more to do with the oil companies.
I mean, they didn't when when oil was 20 to
30 bucks a barrel, they didn't invest now
that it's much higher there.
They want to reap the benefits.
And so the long term solution to this is price
stability, which is more electric vehicles,
more renewable energy so that we're not dictating,
we're not at the mercy of the vagaries of
the price of oil.
But in the short term, I think President Biden
is taking the right action.
Speaker 1: When you when we look at some of
some other things, like, for example, used
cars have been a big area of price increase,
starting with the pandemic and continuing
through building materials is another one,
although it seems that lumber is sort of coming
back down.
How involved do you believe a government should
be on individual areas like these in trying
to influence price?
Speaker 6: As involved as we can be, I mean,
we have to be realistic that the governments
usually don't have that many tools to fight
inflation.
I mean, it goes back to Gerald Ford with wind
and whip inflation and you know, it's very
hard to do, but we should do what we can.
In this case, I think the three things we
need to do is put more money in the pockets
of working families so that they have money
to deal with the higher prices.
Make sure we're dealing with supply chain
issues at the port and make sure we're incentivizing
more people to work so that you can deal with
some of these supply issues and lower prices.
I guess I'd add one more thing, which is if
there's concentrated industry making sure
people aren't charging prices above the competitive
price and putting pressure on those industries
to charge a fair price.
Speaker 2: There is,
Speaker 1: I guess we would call it, plausible.
Maybe we don't have to say probable yet that
Republicans may well take control of the House
of Representatives back next year and would
assume control in January of 2023, given that
we don't know at least what will happen after
next November.
What do you believe realistically can get
done in terms of major legislation in the
next year that that would pass not only the
House, but actually the Senate and become
law?
Speaker 6: Well, first of all, we need to
make sure we win or it's devastating for our
democracy.
I mean, to have people like Marjorie Taylor
Greene and others in charge after the House
of Representatives is a fate that really no
one, in my view in the Democratic side, should,
should want and shouldn't take, should take
very seriously.
I think we have to obviously, we have to pass
build back better with a lower prescription
drug costs, lower child care costs, lower
elder care costs.
We need to, in my view, deliver on the $15
minimum wage.
The president can unilaterally forgive student
loans.
He ought to do that.
Have some forgiveness of student loans.
Voting rights.
We have to deliver voting rights.
This is our chance to do it.
Or we're basically stuck with state voter
suppression laws and we need to make sure
that we're tackling immigration.
I mean, if it doesn't make it into build back
better, there has to be some delivering on
immigration.
So those would be some of the things I think
that are the priorities for next year
Speaker 1: on on student loans.
I got a lot of emails from people who say,
I'm really mad that Joe Biden is not moving
more quickly, unforgiving some student loan
debt.
I came into this presidency not believing
that Joe Biden had any intention of doing
that.
I'm not.
I'm not praising or saying I'm mad at him.
I just never thought that this was a priority
for Joe Biden.
I didn't think he was going to forgive any
student debt.
Is that your view or do you think that that's
something he might be able to be pressured
to do?
Speaker 6: I think you should be persuaded
to do it, I think it can help really build
support in with him, with young people around
the country, and it's the right thing to do,
and he understands that we're being married
to the first lady who was an educator, how
much debt we're saddling the younger generation
with now.
I don't think he's got to do 50000 as Senator
Warren, Senator Schumer and I and others have
asked.
But could he do 10 20000 and would that materially
make a difference in people's lives?
Absolutely.
And I think it would be one of the biggest
things he could do to build momentum for his
presidency.
Speaker 1: You mentioned Marjorie Taylor Greene,
as some in my audience know.
The House voted to strip her of her committee
assignments some months ago.
Your colleague Ayanna Pressley has now suggested
proposed doing the same with with Lauren Boebert
over her multiple recent videos related to
stories about being in elevators with Ilhan
Omar and the jihad squad, et cetera.
What's your view about doing that?
Because it's obviously correct on the merits,
and I would go further that these folks have
no business even being in the House of Representatives.
But is it not a pyrrhic victory in some sense,
where they end up saying I've been canceled,
donate money and it gives them attention?
Speaker 6: Well, David, you're actually right.
I was talking to a friend of mine on the Republican
side yesterday and he said, When are you going
to kick me off my committee so I can go raise
a million bucks an email to my my list?
So this is why I think the speaker is being
judicious about this discussing it.
Obviously, we have to take action.
It has to be clear that that kind of racism,
that kind of Islamophobia has no place.
But we don't want to make.
Representative Barbara Martyr and do something
that's going just further fuel her platform.
And that's why I think the speaker's take
your time consulting the caucus.
I will support whatever action she ends up
taking.
We do need to take some action behind.
Speaker 1: Sometimes we learn that there are
interesting political bedfellows behind the
scenes where publicly there's a lot of conflict
and their friends behind the scenes.
But right now, with some of these personalities
that exist, for example, this rift between
Congresswoman Boebert and Ilhan Omar.
Is there more palpable tension behind the
scenes where it is not nearly as collegial
as it tends to be?
Speaker 6: I think on some of the fringes,
yes, there are a few people who probably you
don't interact with, you don't even sometimes
say hi to.
But not among the vast majority.
I mean, I still have good relations on the
other side.
I was speaking, I speak often.
Representative Kamar, we disagree strongly
on issues of oil and gas, other issues.
But he's always engages in good faith.
There are, you know, dozens of members on
the other side who I still work with.
You have to get legislation through.
Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit about
the general approach that you think the Democratic
Party should take going into the 2022 election.
One of the things that makes it increasingly
tough to run against the kind of modern Republicans
of the Trump and post-Trump era is, for the
most part, they're not even pretending to
be about policy anymore.
They're about obstruction.
They're about cultural issues like critical
race theory or a Christmas tree was burned
and it's part of the war on Christmas or whatever
the case may be.
So that's very silly, but it also makes it
sort of tough to run against them because
if they're not arguing on policy, it's hard
to fight against things like the left wants
to turn this country into a socialist country
or these kind of vague statements.
So how how do you run against that?
I'm not convinced that just continuing to
talk about policy like a train is actually
is is what's effective.
Speaker 6: Well, we lead with patriotism,
we talked about how we have an aspirational
vision for America.
We have a vision of an America where we actually
win the 21st century.
We're proud of being Americans.
Everyone should be taught to be proud of being
Americans, that what we want to make sure
is people shouldn't have to be forced to leave
their hometowns.
We need to bring prosperity and modern opportunity
to places that have long been left out so
that they can have dignity so they can stay.
Kids can stay with their families and that,
you know, Trump promised all these things,
but he hasn't delivered and and we will build
a strong, vibrant, great America.
I think we don't emphasize the patriotism
enough, the aspiration enough.
You have to get to people's hearts to get
them to think, yeah, they really have a vision
that they care about this country.
They care about my community.
And then you can get into the specifics, but
you can't lead with the specifics without.
What is the ED?
What is what is the purpose?
Human beings aren't just economic actors.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's what seems extraordinarily
difficult about the situation, which is I
feel very strongly that when there is a policy
debate, we win the policy debate very clearly.
But if the if the circumstances don't allow
you to be speaking to a public that is expecting
to have the policy debate, and instead they
want the debate over who is socialist or patriotic
or whatever the case may be, it feels like
a losing battle in some sense.
Speaker 6: Well, we can win that debate that
our values are the true American values, our
values of freedom, of ideas and expression,
of respect for people of all faiths, of a
respect for a community of civility and decency.
These are the American values that we're standing
up for and the fulfillment of those values
and a spreading opportunity and prosperity.
I think we ought to frame them as we're standing
up for the deepest American values, the fundamental
American values.
And not that we're here's our five point plan
just to put more money in your pocket.
That matters.
But people care holistically.
They want to see our nation thrive and succeed,
and they want to know what their places in
this nation.
And we have to speak to that deeper aspiration
that people have and people are very much
vote on identity.
Speaker 1: Before I let you go, I'm curious
now in thinking about 2022.
Of course, every member of the house is up
for reelection many and very safe seats, so
the number of truly contested seats is, of
course, only a fraction of the total one-third
of the Senate is, of course, up.
There's a number of governors races, et cetera.
How much talk behind the scenes is there about
the role that the former president Donald
Trump is going to try to play either in general,
in the midterms or in in specific races?
And does it really matter in terms of the
strategy for Democrats?
Speaker 6: I do think he's going to play a
role he's already playing a role in Georgia,
challenging an incumbent governor who's challenging
some sitting House members.
I think it provides an opportunity for Democrats
when the Republican Party is so divided and
they're still having people who are denying
Joe Biden's a legitimate election running
for office on that platform.
But I don't think it's sufficient for Democrats.
I think it gives us an opportunity to compete
to not be written off, to maintain our majority.
But we have to have a vision that delivers
for people and that convinces them that we
really are speaking to what what matters to
them and manage them, not just economically
matters to their conception of our country.
And only if we do that can we can we keep
the house.
Speaker 1: Do you think the Virginia gubernatorial
from last month was a warning about making
it too much about running against Trumpism?
Because Young can seem to kind of ride the
fence well enough that it was not a good strategy?
Speaker 6: Yeah, I don't think it should be
all about Trump, I think you can be also about
some of the extremes in Congress basically
said, Look, do you want some of these people
to be cheering?
The next committee isn't to be in charge of
the the new Congress, but then I think it
has to be a clear vision on our side of what
we have delivered and what we're going to
continue to deliver what we stand for.
People ultimately need the positive, the affirmative
to vote for someone.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
The more I look at next year, the more I'm
of the mindset of hope for the best and prepare
for the worst.
And hopefully it works out.
Not, not too poorly.
Congressman Ro Khanna representing California's
17th District.
Always appreciate your time.
Speaker 6: Thank you, David.
I always enjoy being on.